Marks: Hello there, I'm--
I've been asked
to talk to you about, um,
the social web, um,
and how entrepreneurs
can take advantage of that.
So...the way--
the way I look at this
is that, um,
the web keeps developing
over time.
So it's--the web grew
out of an open network
on open standards.
Um, we built it that way
so that, um,
you could run applications
without worrying about things.
So you didn't have
to worry about
where other computers were,
you could just
send a message to them.
That was the first thing
that happened.
Um, then when we got
to the web, it was,
"I don't have to worry
about where my documents are.
"I can get those
from anywhere in the world.
"Oh, and I don't have
to worry about user interfaces.
"I can just write a form
and the form will post that
to the other side of the world
where my server is."
So there's increasing
abstraction over time.
Um, because these
abstractions are there,
it means, basically,
you have to write less code.
So the trend that's been
happening over the last year,
and the one that we've been
very involved with
in OpenSocial,
is coming up with abstractions
for social--
for the social part
of the web.
Um, a year ago,
what we saw was
there were lots of different
social networking sites,
and people were spending
lots of time on them.
But to develop for them
was very hard.
'Cause each of them
had a separate API.
Um, you often had
to wedge, um, code in there
through--through back doors
or embedding flash
or something like that.
So building something
that worked across many sites
was quite hard.
Um, so we put together
the open social initiative
to come up with a way,
a common set of APIs
for social applications
on the web,
to make the social part
of the web, um,
as easy as writing
HTML forms.
That's the goal, to make it
something you can just
rely on being there.
Um, and a year on,
we're very excited
with what's happened with that.
Um, I'm speaking today from
OpenSocial's first birthday.
Um, and we just announced
that we have
over 600 million users
of OpenSocial worldwide,
across, um, most
of the countries in the world.
I can't even remember
the list of countries.
So that's, um,
that's very exciting.
But the point of this, really,
is that, um, is to make
application development easier.
At the moment, if you want
to build a social application,
you have to find out information
about people.
And that tends to mean
you write a large form
for them to fill in,
where they have to tell you
who they are,
where they live,
any other personal information
you need.
And then the second thing
you have to do
to make it really social
is find out
who their friends are
and gather the same information
from them.
So you either end up saying,
"Tell me who
your friends are,"
or you--they have to re-friend
everyone on your side,
or you go into the
"let me import your address book
and email your friends
and tell them to join my side."
Um, and that ends up
annoying people
more than it helps them.
Um, the other thing is
when you go to a website
that has a big form at the front
asking for information,
people sort of back away from it
and leave.
And so you find that what
you've got into a database
is a sort of bad copy
of their real information
that they store
somewhere else.
'Cause they're a set of sites
they actually trust
with social information.
'Cause those sites are--
specialize in gathering.
So, um, what you're
able to do with OpenSocial
is to draw on those
existing sites
that have
these large collections
of social data,
um, build your application
that specializes
in what you want to do,
um, and then take advantage
of the social network
that already exists.
So you can...whatever
your application's about,
you can almost always
enhance it
by making it more social,
by making it something
you do with friends.
Even if it's just a,
um, a news site
that's telling stories,
um, you can be more
interesting stories
that your friends have
read or recommended,
um, than--than you are
in general
the stories that--that
everyone's looking at.
So by--just by adding that
little social feedback loop,
you can make each, um,
each experience
more interesting.
Um, so another
aspect of this--
now, there--there's--
in building
social applications,
there's a lot of talk
about becoming viral
and spreading.
And--and there's--there's been
a set of applications built
whose primary goal
is to get as many members
as possible.
Um, and this is--
this--this is--
there's, you know, we're seeing
a backlash against that.
And what I like to argue
is that this is--
this is because people
are using the wrong metaphor.
If you think of yourself
as a virus,
you're basically saying,
"I would like
to be a disease.
"I would like to take advantage
or people to spread myself,
and that's my only goal
in life."
So what I say people do
is think of different metaphors.
Think of organic metaphors.
Um, think instead
of infecting someone,
think of inviting them.
Um, so think
of how plants work.
Plants have fruit.
A fruit is a seed,
but it has something delicious
wrapped around it.
If you send someone
an invitation
that actually
makes them happy,
they're much more likely
to follow through,
plant the seed,
and grow it.
So if you se--rather than
sending out invitations
to everyone
in the address book,
um, if you let people
send out photographs
of people,
um, that contain them,
they're much more likely
to look at it.
If I get an email with
"Your friend has
a photograph of you,"
um, I'm gonna look at that,
go back, and click on that.
So think about how you can
actually spread this stuff
so it's a natural part
of the experience
rather than something
you're exploiting
for your--for your own ends.
Because if you behave
like a disease,
people develop
an immune system,
and they learn to reject you,
your applications.
And that's something
we're seeing now.
Um, the applications
that spread rapidly
go up like this,
and they collapse like that
as people start
uninstalling them
and as containers
start banning them.
Um, I said container there,
so I should back up
and explain that a little bit.
Um, with OpenSocial,
we split the development world
into what we call containers
and applications.
The idea is the container
is the custodian
of the social data.
It's the place that knows
who your friends are,
has information
about you and them,
and can reveal that
to the application.
Now, clearly,
they have to do that
with permission
of the users.
So there are
three people involved.
There's the container,
the application,
and the user.
Um, and the user chooses
which applications
to add to the container,
and the container manages
the personal information
so the application doesn't
have to worry about that.
Um, and also, the other--
the key thing,
the value that, um,
the application
gets from the container
is the friends of the user
can see that application too,
and they can learn
to install it.
So it can spread,
um, rapidly in that way.
But, as I say,
you shouldn't be focusing
on spread as your goal.
You should be focusing
on delighting the users
so they want it to spread,
rather than they feel like
something's taking them over
and exploiting them.
Um...the--
so the other thing
that I want to mention
about the growth of OpenSocial
and the way it's changed
in the last year,
um, up until recently,
the model for OpenSocial
has been literally
having an application
embedded inside
somebody else's site.
So if you've got
the container site,
the application was part
of their page.
Um, this has some advantages.
It makes the context
very clear to the user.
It makes it easier
to integrate, um,
the--the friend stuff
'cause it's fairly clear
what's going on.
But the drawback is that, um,
you have to write it
in JavaScript.
Um, and...
well, you can write some
in CSS as well,
but primarily, you're writing
JavaScript application.
Um, and plus
your application
can only actually run code
when somebody's looking at it.
So one of the things
we added in OpenSocial.8
is a REST API,
which makes it easier
for you to write
your application
on your own server over here,
and call
into the social network,
um, use the information
from there,
and present that
back to the user there.
So what we use is a set
of open protocols for that.
We use, um, REST,
which is the basic standard
for communicating on the web.
We use OAuth
to authenticate that,
um, and to let the user say,
"Yes, this application's
allowed to do something
with my application."
Um, and the three parts
of OpenSocial are--
well, actually, there's
four parts of OpenSocial
that are exposed
with REST APIs.
The first is the people
and contact stuff,
finding out who you are,
who your friends are,
and information about you.
Um, the second
is data persistence.
You can actually store data
within the container,
which means when the app
is running in the container,
it can have access
to that quickly.
And also, it handles
the hard problem
of I'm storing information
for user--
for one user.
I need the information
for that user
plus his friends.
Um, for a large number
of users,
that's actually quite
a hard database problem.
But the social networks
have already sold that
because they already have
large numbers of users,
and they solve that problem
every day.
So you're basically
piggybacking
on their ability
to do that there.
The third one
is activity streams.
Now, this is the page
where you have a list
of what you and your friends
have done
within the--
the social network site.
That's been extended
with OpenSocial
so that anything you do
with the applications
could show up in there too.
And with .8, you can
run an application remotely
and send activities
into the site.
So if they do something
on your site,
their friends on the social
network can see that too.
And again, it adds value
for everyone.
It adds value for you
because the social network
where people are watching and
loading the pages 20 times a day
has information
about your applications.
It adds value for, um,
for social network
because stuff that's
happening elsewhere is--
becomes part
of their world.
And it adds value
for the people
'cause they can
keep track of their friends.
So again, you know, you have
this ability to do this.
You could abuse that
and fill it with noise,
but if you do, you'll get
shut down fairly quickly.
So think about how
you can keep that
in a way that adds value
to all three.
Then the fourth thing
is messaging.
You can send messages
to people
through the social network.
Um, and this is--
this is, um, valuable
in that there is
a large group of people
who have moved
from using email
as their primary
messaging system
to using social networks
for that.
Because this--explicitly
because the social networks
are whitelisted.
So if your application
has gained trust
of both parties,
it can send messages
between them.
And that--that makes that
more useful for them too.
So the mod--the model here
is very much adding new
infrastructure to the web
such that every application
you make can become social.
Um, the other, think way
of looking at it
is it's freeing you
from having to maintain
that database of users.
One of the things
you often have to do
in doing web applications
is say,
"Okay, your user database.
I need to start collecting
this stuff."
And it's a sort of bunch
of extra make work
you have to do
at the beginning
before you can focus on
what you really want to build.
So this means that you can
delegate that to other sites
and not worry about, um,
how that works.
And that's--
that's a strong piece
of the, um, what
we're calling the...
um, open stack
of standard protocol
that's for connecting
between sites.
Um, there's--there's a set
of these,
and I won't go
into every place--
OpenID, OAuth,
and OpenSocial
are the three
key ones to know about.
OpenID means using
another site's URL
as a login instead
of an email address.
OAuth means getting
authorization--
letting you use
a grant permission
to access another site
in a standardized way.
And then OpenSocial
is the specification
that defines
what kind of data
you're exchanging
over these connections.
And also has the connection
to the gadget model
so you can actually embed
an application
entirely inside
another site as well.
Man: Great.
- Kevin: Okay.
- Man: Nice job.
Kevin: How long was that?